pour se venger de son ex son ex qui est
kim Kardashian West le frère de sushi
révèle ses problèmes intestinaux sur
Instagram c'est la guerre entre Kim et
Kenny Kenny ne cesse d'attaquer Kim
vraiment après avoir insulté sa famille
son copain il a décidé de s'attaquer à
son transit histoire de fou il a déclaré
sur Instagram kimala diarrhée très
souvent genre beaucoup plus que ce que
devrait avoir une personne normale Kim
race du area
elle envoie en spray
c'est incroyable quand même est-ce que
vous trouvez ça ce que vous trouvez ça
petit voilà oui Kelly veut devenir le
gars ne devrait vraiment pas être fier
parce que quelqu'un qui fait autant aux
toilettes à ce point-là c'est quelqu'un
qui n'est pas heureux et qui est stressé
par la vie donc je pense qu'elle est
bien contente d'être séparée de ce
mec-là parce qu'il devait vraiment la
stresser un peu un ouf à mon avis là son
transit va mieux il y a un rapport entre
la diarrhée et le bonheur
ne dit-on pas j'en chie avec toi
[Applaudissements]
une énorme star il est milliardaire on
pourrait croire qu'il est déconnecté des
réalités et là il montre que il a le
seum comme tout le monde quand il se
fait larguer par son ex on se rend sympa
franchement j'aime bien mais ça le rend
pas du tout sympa
c'est dégueulasse quelle est la diarrhée
ou pas ça nous regarde pas en fait c'est
sa vie privée je trouve que c'est ça en
commun
justement il s'en prend à travers les
enfants on sait que on sait que comme
Kelly c'est vrai quand on est en couple
quand on va beaucoup aux toilette c'est
que on est stressé je sais que Fatou
nous regarde les toilettes
ça tourne pense à toi voilà et on t'aime
voilà il voudrait que leur fille Norse
aille dans son académie dans son école
la maman ne veut pas il s'en prend à la
mer
et donc leur nom de famille c'est ouest
c'est une boussole
les gars c'est quoi cette cadavre
et comme la maman veut pas qu'elle
change d'école du coup il tape sur toute
la famille je trouve ça dégueulasse
qu'il a été oui quelqu'un veut réagir
non mais c'est vrai est-ce qu'il y en a
un mec si vous avez fait un truc grave à
part décédé non mais c'est vrai
franchement
est-ce qu'un jour on est un jour il
paraît qu'il y a un ex qui a oublié son
dentier
dans le matelas sous le matelas il avait
caché sous le matelas et là elle a
entendu
il y avait personne c'est juste dentier
en fait voilà avec la clim qui s'est mis
à claquer des dents mais c'est vrai
voilà merci en tout cas voilà et
franchement c'est horrible comme ça
ton ex parce qu'il savait que ma passion
enfin j'avais deux passions dans la vie
c'est quoi aussi qu'il était la
troisième passion l'argent les voitures
et voilà malheureusement vous n'avez pas
le permis pour le coup c'était horrible
parce que je m'étais fait un beau cadeau
je m'étais offert à l'époque une
Mercedes que j'aimais beaucoup
ASL un peu vraiment un truc et j'adore
ça et on s'est disputé et tout ça et le
matin il dormait chez moi et le matin
comme Subaru il était plus là je suis
jusque là c'est pas très grave c'est une
serrure à changer et je vais au parking
et il y avait marqué sur tout le long de
la voiture comme ça petite [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
moi quand je vois marquer avant sur une
voiture c'est vrai
tout un côté de voiture bah voilà c'est
un artiste
d'abord c'est pas couvert pas c'est
compliqué de sortir avec une voiture il
y a marqué ça bah c'est sûr mais voilà
mais mais en plus et l'assurance a
repris en charge non
je disais que c'était comment vous avez
expliqué ça mais c'était dans la rue et
que c'est un expert qui est passé oui
effectivement
je suis sur les lieux et écoute il y a
effectivement marqué petite [ __ ]
mais il a vu qu'effectivement il y avait
quelqu'un voilà bah bravo à lui en tout
cas très bonne initiative